what we're going to do in this video is
get a little bit more practice
constructing lewis diagrams and in
particular we're going to try to
construct the lewis diagram for
formaldehyde formaldehyde has one carbon
two hydrogens and an oxygen
ch2o so pause this video and have a go
at it try to construct a valid lewis
structure or lewis diagram for
formaldehyde
all right now let's do this together
now the first step and we saw this in a
previous video we want to think about
all of the valence electrons for this
molecule so we want to account
account
for
valence electrons now the reason why we
want to do that is so that while we're
trying to create this structure we are
making use of all of the valence
electrons and to figure out how many
total valence electrons we have we can
look at a periodic table of elements we
can see that carbon is in that second
row in that second period so its second
shell is its outer shell and in that
shell it has one two three four valence
electrons so carbon has four valence
electrons
a neutral free hydrogen atom is going to
have one valence electron but we have
two of them
here so it's going to be two times one
and then oxygen
it also is in the second period and in
its second shell it has one two three
four five six valence electrons and so
the total valence electrons in this
molecule are going to be 4 plus
2 which is 6 plus 6 which is equal to 12
valence electrons
now the next step is to try to draw a
structure try to
draw
draw single bonds i'll say single
bonds and a key question is what do we
think is going to be our central atom
and the rule of thumb is the least
electronegative atom that is not
hydrogen
is a good candidate for our central atom
so we can rule out hydrogen so between
carbon and oxygen we know that oxygen is
one of the most electronegative atoms
one of the most electronegative elements
on the periodic table of elements it's
very close to fluorine and so carbon is
a good candidate for the central atom
so let's put the carbon
right
over here
and then let's put these other atoms
around it let's we could call them
terminal atoms so let's put our oxygen
right over there and then we have two
hydrogens hydrogen there a hydrogen
there and let me draw
the bonds so that's a single bond that
accounts for two valence electrons that
accounts for two valence electrons that
accounts for two valence electrons so
i've just used two four six valence
electrons so if i subtract six valence
electrons i am now left with
six valence electrons six
valence electrons so the next step is
allocate the remaining valence electrons
trying to get to the octet rule for
atoms that are not hydrogen and then for
hydrogen trying to get it to have two
valence electrons so allocate
allocate remaining
remaining
valence electrons
all right so let's start with this
oxygen this oxygen already has these two
electrons that it's sharing hanging
around so in order to get to the octet
rule it needs six more so let's give it
six electrons
so
one two three four five
six
well i've just used up the remaining six
valence electrons
so i don't really have any more to play
with let's see how the other atoms are
feeling so hydrogen here it's able to
share these two electrons that are in
this covalent bond so it's feeling good
it can kind of pretend that it has a
full outer shell because it's outer
shell is just that one that first shell
that's filled with two electrons same
thing for this other hydrogen so at
least the terminal atoms the oxygen and
the two hydrogens are feeling like they
have a full outer shell but in the
fourth step we're going to look
at our central atom
so
let's focus on the central atom
central atom and do we need more bonds
or do we need to do something
interesting here and what we see is that
carbon it's able to have two four six
electrons hanging around it but it would
love to have eight carbon would love to
have a full outer shell so how could we
do that
well we could add more bonds where could
the bonds come from well it would come
from some lone pair of electrons well
the only lone pairs of electrons are
hanging around this oxygen so what if we
were to take say this lone pair of
electrons and then construct another
covalent bond with that
then
our
lewis diagram will look like this i will
actually redraw it so you have your
carbon
you have
your
three original covalent bonds
you had a hydrogen a hydrogen
and then you had your
oxygen right over here
and now we formed a new covalent bond
just like this
and then you have these two other lone
pairs around the oxygen so let me draw
that so
two and then another two around the
oxygen and this is looking pretty good
because the oxygen it still has eight
electrons hanging around four in lone
pairs and then four that in this double
bond that it is sharing the hydrogens
still have two electrons hanging around
they're able to share the electrons in
each of these covalent bonds and now the
carbon is participating in you could
think of it as four covalent bonds two
single bonds and one double bond so each
of those have two electrons associated
with it so it has eight electrons
hanging around so this is looking really
good as a legitimate
lewis structure or lewis diagram
for formaldehyde